have something for the first lady she
had made such a great contribution to
his campaign
although Jackie did not have a real love
of politics that she never received the
credit for the work she did because in
the presidential primaries in Wisconsin
West Virginia as many men stood in line
to shake Jackie's hand as women did to
shave jacks this is a piece that you
love when she went to the India and
Pakistan it's a beautiful model of the
Shalimar Gardens it had never ever been
on display before and of course we have
a Jackie one enemy on the for her tour
of the White House during the Kennedy
years when I was first married I like
was almost as hectic as it is now and I
defend about it rather hard to adjust
but now I think politics is what is most
rewarding life the women have to be lied
to a politician I think every woman was
still needed and in politics you are
from with more than many other things
you always living in the state of crisis
you're always being demanded to meet
challenge and when you made it it's a
great satisfaction - ladies and
gentlemen mr. president one of the
Kennedys that does not need interpreters
hysterical nor sense el deseo crew fondo
de memory foam the ayudar a los sinuses
Quintana Roo la estoy seguro que con
west collaboration and Canberra méxico
hasta luego gosh
I know when we went to Columbia the
presidential palace there as all the
history of that country in it we're seen
one Bolivar was every piece of furniture
in it has some link with the past
I thought the White House should be like
that this chest is rather interesting as
you know the thing we care about most is
something that belong to a past
president this little chest was left by
President Van Buren to his grandson it
has writing inside it which shows all
that and this because we like to have
mainly American furniture and things is
rather like Staffordshire but it's
American pottery which is very rare of
the early 19th century with an eagle in
the shield on it the thing I care about
most is to make it more of him Avenue
them with more pieces of beautiful
furniture that belong to old president
is very little antique furniture here
now and what what is dates from 19 -
it's really an 18th century house it was
designed in 1792 by James Hoban who was
an Irishman and he modeled it quite loud
on Leinster house and Dublin so it is an
18th century house but it has many
things of later periods in it
there's only little privacy I don't mind
for myself but I think it's very hard
with them for instance I want to take my
daughter to the circus last week and I
decided I just shouldn't because I would
ruin it for her I worked so hard to make
her little ballet school a private thing
that we could do together and they were
all the photographer's waiting when we
got there so it's a little hard I think
it doesn't matter what else you do if
you don't do that part well if you fail
your husband and your children that
really is the row which means most of me
though obviously I have a deep sense of
obligation for the others but that's the
one that comes first